well the Democratic Party has always had
some splits at least for a long time
they have they were split over civil
rights even when kennedy and johnson may
bear historic decisions to put the
democratic party behind the civil rights
movement in this country and prohibit
discrimination and segregation on the
basis of race and that split as
continued the Vietnam War which Johnson
unfortunately entered and escalated
after Kennedy had proven to be too smart
to put anything more that advisors and
instructors in that split the party
along grounds of conscience and and
moral issues but to some extent along
the lines of age so they split between
the establishment of the Democratic
Party and the those who are more
idealistic has existed for some time
it's being reflected now in the split
behind the establishment folks in
Washington who are behind Hillary and
those are in the young people in the
grassroots who are behind obama and when
Obama is elected I know the
establishment well enough to know they
will get behind him very rapidly and I
believe he'll be able to not only unite
the Democratic Party I believe as never
before you will unite the country both
parties independents Republicans as well
as Democrats
you